[Musique]
Hollywood mais beaucoup d'argent sur la
table par les acteurs et les actrices
ils sont très très universels c'est une
question d'argent en même temps
depuis quelques années nous essayons
quand même de choisir des documentaires
qui sont liés à la cinématographique
[Musique]
c'est 5 heures exceptionnels de du
business à Hollywood où on voit que
depuis Edison finalement Hollywood
cherche une recette économique et
marketing le cinéma a vécu pendant
presque un siècle un peu moins sur
l'idée sur l'idée d'un rêve où les
coulisses étaient sinon fermés ou en
tout cas pas très ouverte au grand
public il nous paraissait nécessaire ou
intéressant de savoir comment ça se
fonctionnait
fil de son histoire Hollywood a vécu et
est passé de mains en main les grands
studios ont été fondés par des
immigrants
ces immigrants eux-mêmes vendu le studio
à des groupes des groupes industriels
qui n'avaient rien à voir avec le cinéma
donc voilà cette évolution
essentiellement commerciale mais c'est
vrai aussi que le cinéma est le seul art
qui nécessite tout en argent
[Musique]
la plupart des films américains c'est
des sciences fictions et ça moi je
trouve que on en a marre de voir ces
films je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
blockbusters sont beaucoup mis en valant
en valeur mais qu'on a beaucoup de
choses et de réalisatrices réalisateur à
découvrir qui a pas encore de petites
talents et de mise en scène de metteur
en scène à avoir
[Musique]
il n'y a rien à opposer les plateformes
et les salles de cinéma doivent
fonctionner ensemble il faut revoir la
chronologie des médias avec du bon sens
et de l'intelligence au niveau
d'aujourd'hui ces planétaires Hollywood
d'une certaine manière à infuser comme
ça dans le monde entier Hollywood c'est
la télévision Hollywood c'est la vidéo
au niveau de ses Netflix c'est Amazon
c'est
quelle que soit le propriétaire de
l'Hollywood
Hollywood a survécu à tout donc pourquoi
pas aux plateformes et au niveau d'usage
[Musique]